hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
explore methods for more efficient
molecular cloning and strain engineering
applications
i am michelle ashton of labyrus and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by molecular devices
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen
to obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dwayne e carter field application
scientist at molecular devices
dwayne you may now begin your
presentation
molecular cloning is a valuable
technique utilized by many molecular
biologists to study biological traits
through in vitro gene copy the
traditional molecular cloning process
involves the isolation of dna
that are ligated into prepared vectors
such as plasmids containing unique
restriction sites for cloning in foreign
dna and antibiotic resistance genes
assembled dna plasmids enable the
transformation of microbes such as
complement bacteria
with the defined dna sequences as the
bacteria multiplies so does the inserted
foreign dna which is typically screened
by a colony picking and confirmed via
dna analysis
while the molecular cloning process has
not changed since its discovery over 50
years ago the demand for molecular
cloning has quickly risen to the
spotlight as we identify new pathways
and drugable targets with clinical
implications to treat many diseases
using recombinant proteins and the
development of diagnostic probes to
detect infectious diseases such as
coping 19 or to develop vaccines against
them
our improved understanding of the
genetic code over the last 50 years has
allowed us to read write copy and
synthesize dna faster than ever
this allows us to quickly identify
beneficial genes within biological
pathways and engineer those genes to
produce more favorable strains of
organisms
capable of acting as bioreactors
producing more favorable products such
as environmental biosensors and food
products
if you've ever eaten the impossible
burger sold by burger king and other
popular restaurants then you have taken
a bite of an engineered food product
the meat flavor that you taste comes
from heme
this is an iron-containing molecule
found in a soybean protein that was
isolated from fermented yeast
genetically engineered with the gene for
soy like hemoglobin
most biologists are familiar with how
evolution has resulted in the incredible
diversity and beneficial adaptations
found in nature
directed evolution as depicted in this
figure is a form of strain engineering
that utilizes a simple strategy where
genes of interest are rapidly mutated
screened and selected for favorable
phenotypes such as increased enzyme
activity and subsequent production of
favorable bioproducts such as biofuels
currently directed evolution using
genetic engineering methods and protein
design using computer technology are the
most too common methods of enzyme
engineering
while this is a valuable approach to
food and fuel sustainability while
making efforts to combat climate change
the high throughput nature of this
process possesses major challenges in
bottlenecks when screening and selecting
tens of thousands of mutants a day while
also managing large libraries of dna
the approach used to clone a specific
gene depends to a large degree on the
gene in question and what is known about
it
generally the procedure starts with a
sample of dna such as genomic dna which
is fragmented to generate multiple
clones
of this fragmented dna
this collection of clones is called a
dna library
in strain engineering there are a number
of synthetic dna library types that are
constructed from wild-type genes of
interest to produce clones with
favorable phenotypes
in this first example we have a alanine
scan library where key amino acids are
substituted with alanine causing changes
in epitope binding activity
so next we have site saturation
mutagenesis library where substitutes of
specific codon sites against all 20
possible amino acids happen at once
we have also the combinatorial
mutagenesis library where
multiple sites are mutated within a
sequence at once
and for a more directed evolutionary
process we have error-prone pcr which
can be used to drive random mutagenesis
to generate a de novo evolved protein
with improved folding stability
solubility and ligand binding activity
these techniques can be used to build
antibody libraries
promoter regulation libraries and quite
often many of these library types are
constructed simultaneously resulting in
tens of thousands of clones and large
dna libraries to screen for favorable
phenotypes
in a molecular cloning workflow genes of
interest are amplified synthesized and
assembled into vectors then inserted
into microbes via a process known as
transformation for gene copy
transform microbes are plated and street
onto agar plates for growth then
colonies are manually screened and
picked based on size color fluorescence
or proximity then inoculated into the
broth for downstream hit identification
and library management
while there have been many improvements
to remove bottlenecks such as low
ligation efficiency
frequency of dna mutations and dna loss
during purification typically observed
in dna synthesis and dna assembly
many bottlenecks still exist if you are
manually plating and streaking screening
and tracking hundreds to thousands of
colonies per day
here are some of the major bottlenecks
seen in the molecular cloning workflow
planing and streaking off transformed
bacteria is a very important step in the
molecular cloning process because if
done correctly
it will result in discrete colonies for
picking
this is a very time consuming process
and even the best techniques employed
you can still result in uneven streaking
and overgrowth thus making this manual
process inefficient as well
whether you are using pipette tips or
toothpicks as depicted here manual
colony picking is a slow laborious and
time consuming process that is highly
subjective and prone to human error
manual data tracking and library
database management for small sample
sizes can be challenging time consuming
and prone to user errors so this process
will certainly create bottlenecks if
higher throughput is
required the video on the left
demonstrates manual bacterial colony
picking using pipette tips which are
inoculated into deep well blocks with
growth media on the right we have our
cupix automated microbial colony picker
picking and inoculating bacterial
colonies at a much faster rate into deep
well blocks with growth media
automation can reduce operational costs
deliver more accuracy and streamline
your workflow while increasing
productivity and capacity automated
colony pickers such as our cupix 420
shown here is a great entry level unit
for groups looking to increase the
throughput and efficiency of their
colony screen
with only 90 seconds to set up you have
the ability to pick up to 12
96 wealth weights before needing manual
intervention
this translates to up to 3 000 colonies
screened per hour or 30 000 colonies per
day
additional pleating and streaking and
library management features with
complete audit trail and sample tracking
makes it an entire library management
system taking the guesswork out of
sample tracking
additionally it is automation friendly
for integration with other instruments
on the left we have our cupix 420 model
which is considered our base model
offering automated colony screening and
picking
on the right we have our cupix select ht
model which has the liquid handling
feature for plating and streaking of
microbial stocks onto agar plates
and also has automated colony screening
and picking functions
it is automation or integration friendly
and compared to manual colony screening
our cupix users have higher throughput
of up to 2 700 more colonies per hour
with at least 45 minutes of walk away
time per hour on our cupix 420 are no
hands-on time at all with our cupix
select ht model with robotic arm
integration
these two models of colony pickers will
reduce your timeline to find those
clones with favorable traits reduce fte
hours and save you money on consumable
costs
the cubix is equipped with many features
that make it suitable for automation
the actuator head is considered the
brains of the operation and contains a
high resolution camera used to image and
screen colonies as well as
interchangeable pins
used for picking various size colonies
and other applications
the actuator head also contains a
barcode reader for reliable traceability
of data as well as an acoustic agar
height sensor to enable gentle and
accurate picking of single columns
the cupix has a flexible bed design and
is considered plate agnostic to
accommodate a wide variety of plate
types including segmented q-trays single
or eight-way omni trays and various size
petri dishes as source plates
as for destination plates any sbs
formatted plates in standard or deep
well configuration including pcr plates
are compatible with the cupix
the cupix is equipped with built-in pin
sterilization wash baths and halogen
heat sterilization to eliminate
cross-contamination and in some
instances reduce plastic consumption
the cupix is also future proof with its
modular ability to integrate with
robotics and other instruments to give
you more
walk away time
and increase throughput
here we take a closer look at our
stainless steel picking pins that vary
in size shape or surface area to
accommodate for picking various size and
types of microbes
as seen here the cupix has a wide range
of applications
from plating and streaking biological
samples onto agar
with planing volumes ranging anywhere
between 10 to 130 microliters to imaging
and selective screening of colonies
using high resolution cameras
that capture whole receptacles and
allows the screening of colonies using
white light fluorescence blue and white
and zone of inhibition
there is also an application for
gridding colonies onto filter sheets or
conducting agata transfer
as well
the cubic software not only
automatically creates an audit trail for
easy database management but also has
applications such as replication and
rearing for better library management
and efficient storage which i'll expand
on shortly
using the cupix software you can easily
teach the software what a best colony
looks like based on shape
size proximity and fluorescence
intensity which results in accurate and
consistent colony picking
these images demonstrate that the cupix
can image colonies in white light and
fluorescence and gate colonies based on
required levels of target protein
expression
the cubics is compatible with a broad
range of fluorescent cloning vectors
because it can capture images in four
fluorescent channels that can be used to
screen selection markers after
transformation or for mutation screens
to quickly pre-screen colonies with
optimal expression levels as seen in the
raw fluorescent image
which shows differences in expression
levels
the cupix can also
screen fuse
fluorescent proteins to study protein
folding secretion enzyme evolution or
protein localization
the software has a really robust
database management system with ability
to track pick runs and plates picked
from and into and easily export this
data for sample tracking
here is an example of how the cupix data
review process enhances visibility of
history and location of pick colonies
with the option to customize tags of
important samples for easy sample
tracking
in the source plate we see
the exact location of the pig colonies
with plate type barcode
and date and time stamp of the picking
event
on the destination plate we see the well
that was inoculated with the pit colony
and the same data tracking as seen on
the source plate
having the ability to compress and
expand sample banks users can automate
the process of creating sample banks
while eliminating errors
here we show the ability to create
duplicates and sub-libraries to maintain
clone viability via compression of
496 well plates into one 384 well plate
or expansion of one 384 well plate into
496 wood plates
users can also cherry pick desirable
colonies from multiple plates and
consolidate this these colonies into a
single plate for more efficient sample
management
so thus far you've seen how the cupix
automates plating and streaking colony
screening and picking inoculation and
library management so let's take a look
at how integration
can help automate more upstream and
downstream processes in a molecular
cloning workflow
adding a robotic arm with ambient plate
storage hotels is a simple but proven
way to increase throughput and walk away
time on a molecular cloning workflow
using our cupix select ht microbial
colony picking system
on the left we have a side view of the
cupix with the plate hotel and robotic
arm located behind the instrument
and on the right we are showing the back
of the cupix which is open to accept the
robotic arm which in this picture is
bringing a source pleat filled with
microbial colonies to be screened and
picked on the cupix
sorry
here is the short video showing an
automated cupid select ht in action with
the robotic arm and ambient plate hotel
integration a precise flex pf400 robotic
arm is positioned to the rear of the
cupix which allows easy access to
customizable ambient plate hotels for
storage of plates going into and out of
cupix
here we see a 96 well plate being loaded
onto the bed of the cupix from the plate
hotel
with the robotic arm
the cupix quickly picks screen colonies
that will be inoculated into 96 well
played
these destination plates can be stored
in shaking our static incubators for
growth in manual mode are in full
automation mode using the same
integrated robotic arm
modern synthetic biology workflows are
iterative design build test cycles that
encompass the decisions and actions
necessary to design build and test
target genetic systems
the design process defines the problem
and develops an initial design
the build process is where components
such as genes and vectors are selected
synthesized and assembled to incorporate
into the preferred host
the test phase is where the design is
validated
the learned component scrutinizes the
test data which can inform further
iterations of the cycle
historically such cycles have been
performed manually with limited formal
problem definition and progress tracking
researchers have devoted substantial
effort to define and automate many
sub-problems of these cycles to create
workflows that include data management
and tracking as part of the automation
package
this is a simplified workflow that was
created for a customer who is interested
in metabolically engineering the
overproduction
of fatty acids from e coli to conduct
catalytic conversion to alkanes as a
biofuel
as previously shown the design process
defines the problem and identifies the
pathway within the e coli that produces
fatty acids and which genes within that
pathway would be targeted to engineer
the desired effect
gene mutants can be designed in silico
and synthesized by companies like idt
which ship the dna and vectors
the genes are assembled into vectors on
the liquid handler and thermocycler or
heat block then subsequently used to
transform e coli using a thermocycler or
heat block
transformers are plated and streaked
onto agar plates on the cupids then
incubated overnight before colonies are
screened picked and inoculated into
broth on our pupix automated colony
picker
plasmids are isolated on the liquid
handler using
the user's preferred kits then a sample
is allocated onto the liquid handler for
dna sequencing while organic additives
are added to the remaining culture for
fatty acid extraction and conversion to
alkenes
learning is conducted and the design
process starts again for future
optimization if needed
so some problems require slightly
different solutions so we have put
together a list of instruments that we
have demonstrated seamless integration
with our cupix
we have already covered our cupix colony
picker so let's start from number two
here in this list
the biomec i7 from beckmanncoulter
supports the mixing of small volumes in
96 to 384 well played format on a
spacious open platform design that
enables access from all sides to allow
for robotic arm integration and manual
loading of reagents
glyconic incubators are automation
friendly humidity temperature and co2
control
and range in capacities from 44 to 500
standard micro wheel plates or 22 to 250
deep well plates with sps footprint
capacities
so
it has both the option to have static
and shaking capabilities for microbial
growth as well making these
automated incubators very versatile
in a molecular cloning work cell
even the little things like capping and
decapping screw cap tubes barcode
labeling microplate sealing and peeling
can be integrated and automated to
drastically reduce fte hours while
processing hundreds of plates and tubes
in a single experiment
through these bottlenecks on the liquid
handler a multi-drop dispenser can be
integrated into the molecular cloning
workflow which dispenses a wide range of
volumes into microwave plates ranging
from six well plates to 1536 well plates
the on-deck thermocyclers are compact
endpoint pcr thermocyclers with
programmable temperature profiles
and lid temperatures ranging from 30
degrees centigrade to 150 degrees
centigrade that can accommodate 96 to 3d
four well microplate arrays
many of our customers use this
instrument for dna assembly and
bacterial transformations so depending
on your throughput multiple
thermocyclers can be integrated in
vertical fashion
to reduce or eliminate bottlenecks
depending on your
throughput the automated plate
centrifuge is a small footprint
stackable plate centrifuge with high
centrifugal force peaking at 4000 g's
with cooling to maintain ambient control
this instrument is detrimental for
pelleting your transform microbes after
the growth phase and for downstream
plasmid analysis as well
the spectromax id5 multi-mode plate
reader is the cornerstone of a complete
laboratory solution to help you expand
the boundaries of your research
capabilities with optimized reagents and
the industry leading data acquisition
and analysis to softmax pro 7 software
the spectromax id5 allows you to
customize your workflow to perfectly
match your needs
so if you're doing assays that of course
in molecular cloning will require od
to assess the growth of your microbes or
conducting qc analysis of proteins or
metabolites the versatility of the id5
to read plates
in absorbance fluorescence intensity and
luminescence makes it
a need in the design build learn test
process
additionally a spectromax abs plate
reader can be added to your workflow to
specifically assess the growth of your
microbes
as an assessment of absorbance thereby
eliminating any potential bottlenecks
that may arise when the multi-mode plate
reader is being used for downstream
functional and tighter analysis
the 5400 fragment analyzer automated
electrophoresis system is capable of
resolving a wide range of dna and rna
fragment sizes
with as low as 3 base pair resolution
with high sizing accuracy for fragments
under 300 base pairs the fragment
analyzer is a crucial step for reducing
the time taken for hit identification
the robotic arm is an integral part of
all our automated work cells because it
is the instrument that connects them all
the precise flex robotic arm is capable
of gripping
littling and deleting standard sps
footprints microplates and is iso one
five zero six six compliant
with a two meter track system and the
ability to move in the vertical or
z-axis to access instruments along the
length of the work cell as well as the
instruments stacked vertically for
customers who need more throughput but
have space constraints
the green button go software by biocero
is an easy to use drag and drop style
dynamic scheduling platform that
communicates to integrated instruments
via their application programming
interface or api
and manages the delivery of plates to
and from all integrated instruments on
the work cell
so each step of the workflow has been
programmed as a work cell process within
the green button go software and
estimates for timing and throughput are
determined around the number and types
of plates from each of these processes
based on the user's specific workflow
will be transformed by a heat shock on
the thermocyclers then plated streaked
screened and picked in the cupix
then incubated for growth in the lyconic
incubators
the liquid handler will perform all
small volume mixing and the high g
centrifuge in orange
will pellet bacteria and elude plasmid
dna using your preferred dna extraction
kits
bacterial od readings and protein
readouts from expression bacterial cells
are analyzed on the id5 plate reader
a workflow like this typically takes up
around 8 by 14 feet of lab space but one
of the cool features of our work cells
is the ability to stack instruments
vertically using shells
this gives customers who have limited
lab lateral lab space the opportunity to
have a fully automated molecular cloning
workflow despite their space limitations
there is a top-down view of a very large
work cell where our customer was
interested in increased throughput and
walk-away time while having a hepa
enclosure around the instruments
to connect the two halves of the work
cell we integrated two robotic arms on
either side with a track very similar to
a train track in the middle to shuttle
plates from one side of the work cell to
the other or to static and shaking
incubators located in the middle of the
work cell
one robotic arm has the ability to
automate
large q trays and that's located on the
left
as source plates in the cupics now this
will improve throughput and efficiency
of colony picking because these large q
trays can be segmented up to 48 segments
on one tray
the other robotic arm is only equipped
to automate sbs format microplates
so here is a 3d view of that work cell
also with the hepa enclosure in place
health team is a multi-disciplinary team
who does the customization and
integration of our clone screening
technologies with other technologies to
meet the customer's needs
oz is capable of scalable automation
where we adapt our instruments to
seamlessly integrate into larger lab
automation workstations or design and
test whole workstations from scratch
we also have customized solutions where
we offer services
from consultation through implementation
this includes throughput analysis
software and hardware customization
factory acceptance test site acceptance
test and instrument validation on site
finally our os team offers something
that is very unique
in biological validation where we work
with you to understand your process and
biological requirements so we can
produce and test the actual performance
in-house prior to shipment
so within reason and some physical
limitations of course if you dream it we
will make it awesome
here you can see three examples of
colony picking with the qpx along with
integration of shaking incubation
peeling and sealing and automated
storage and finally high capacity
storage in q-tray automation using a
robotic arm
what's cool about the cupix is that you
don't have to buy all of your integrated
hardware up front
because it is modular we can scale with
you as your workflow scales and adapt to
your workflow if it changes so you're
not locked into one configuration for
automation and integration
the cupix is equipped to provide
workflow solutions for a number of
methods
and processes including microbial
screening of course such as molecular
cloning and even phage display for
antibody discovery
our instrumentation will allow you to
fast track your timeline by removing the
hurdles in clone screening through
accelerating the selection and
characterization of your clones
thus increasing throughput and walk away
time with robust documentation that can
increase your confidence in your data
tracking and library management
as you know our customers span the
spectrum of life science research pharma
biotech government universities and in
nearly every research lab across the
globe you will find labs performing
cellular analysis
our intimate knowledge of these
customers provides a great opportunity
for molecular devices to provide
complete workflow solutions no matter
the problem
thank you so much for your time and
attention if you have any remaining
questions that we were not able to
answer during the allotted time for this
webinar or you'd like to be contacted by
a local account representative please
visit moleculardevices.com
thank you duane for your informative
presentation we'll now go ahead and
start the q a portion of the webinar
again if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started our
first question is
where do you see synthetic biology
making the most difference in society
in the next decade
all right i can see
synthetic biology uh plan having a huge
impact in the foods we eat and the fuels
that we use
um because synthetic biology is really
not about the
the process but really about the intent
the intent is for us to have sustainable
food sources and fuel sources in the
future
and i think if we can understand
our own biology as it exists right now
and and engineer it to produce what we
want i think we're we're going to be
able to attain
um those goals based on our intent
all right your next question is how do
you pick colonies that appear hollow in
the center
but they are good pickable qualities
if you adjust both the imaging exposure
and gain settings to allow the entire
colony to appear as a circular entity
that should allow you to get in these
colonies quite easily
all right thank you your next question
um can i pick a colony on aeger and go
to anger plate with multi-dips to make
new colonies
good question um
the cubic software does have agar to
agar plate gridding so yes it is
possible for you to do that
okay and our last question today can i
export coordinates of colonies pit
yes so our software audit trail can
export colonies um coordinates sorry of
colonies picked along with destination
plate wells that they were picked into
all right well thank you so much swain
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go today
um not at the moment
um just you know if you have any
questions uh please visit
moleculardevices.com and reach out to us
we look forward to hearing from you
all right well thanks again for your
time today we would also like to thank
labruz and our sponsor molecular devices
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
as a reminder any questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time goodbye